ich bin unterwegs im Epizentrum des
türkischen erdbebengebiets in Hatay
sechs Monate danach leben die meisten
noch immer in trümmerlandschaften und
kämpfen auch gegen enorme
Schadstoffbelastung
mein erstes Ziel ein ganz persönlicher
Ort an dem ich früher so viel Zeit
verbracht habe
das ist das Haus meiner Großeltern vor
sechs Monaten beim Erdbeben eingestürzt
ich habe hier viele Kindheit
Sommerferien verbracht und habe nur die
schönsten Erinnerungen und das mit den
eigenen Augen zu sehen das tut richtig
weh
[Musik]
hallo Onkel wie geht's
zentrale Kippe
mein Onkel michelle ist hier zu Hause er
hatte Glück konnte sich in letzter
Sekunde mit einem Sprung aus diesem
Fenster retten
ich habe mich am Baum festgehalten mit
dem Rücken zum Garten und im Gesicht zum
Haus
das Haus fiel in dem Moment zusammen ein
schaukeln und wackeln ich fühlte mich
buchstäblich wie auf einem fliegenden
Teppich es war furchtbar
wegen der starken Nachbeben verbrachte
mein Onkel die ersten 15 Nächte bei
Eiseskälte im Auto seitdem lebt er in
einem Provisorium immerhin zählte und
Container stehen auf seinem Grundstück
das im Freien kochen muss daran hat er
sich inzwischen gewöhnt
Haus bin ich sehr traurig aber nach
einiger Zeit habe ich die Traurigkeit
vergessen weil so viele Freunde und
Bekannte von mir durch das Erdbeben
gestorben sind
mehr als 50.000 Menschen sind nach
offiziellen Angaben ums Leben gekommen
die UN spricht von einer
jahrhundert-katastrophe Muna hat das
Erdbeben alles genommen auf dem Friedhof
von Samantha liegen Ihre Liebsten
begraben der Besuch kostet sie jedes Mal
Kraft und Überwindung
ich bin für jeden Moment dankbar den wir
zusammen erleben konnten
der Sohn die Schwiegertochter Esra ihr
Enkelkind und ihr Mann nie hat
erschlagen von herabfallenden Decken und
Mauern in ihrem gemeinsamen Haus
Mona überlebte lag 14 Stunden schwer
verletzt in den Trümmern neben ihrem
Mann
er redete ständig weiter er hatte
Schmerzen
und verabschiedete sich von mir
er sagte Mona unsere Kinder sind tot und
auch ich werde sterben
ich liebe dich
mona ist vorübergehend in eine andere
Stadt gezogen zu groß ist der Schmerz zu
nah die Erinnerung die Sie mit diesem
Ort verbindet
ich habe solche Sehnsucht immer aber was
los die kleinen
Klopfen auf seinen Kopf als wäre es eine
Trommel
die selbstgebaute Vorschule überstand
die Beben es war der Lebenstraum ihrer
Schwiegertochter die Lehrerin war
Mona will die Schule jetzt weiterführen
als eine Art Vermächtnis
wir fahren in die berühmte Altstadt
antakyas oder das was von ihr noch übrig
blieb
dann richtig sprachlos hier
92% der Gebäude sind zerstört und was
das Beben stehen ließ reißen jetzt die
Bagger ganze Stadtviertel sind
verschwunden von Wiederaufbau ist hier
noch wenig zu sehen
Antag hier ist wahrscheinlich die Welt
abrisshauptstadt Nummer eins warum wird
sehr schnell deutlich wenn man sich hier
umschaut weil alles was hier steht wird
abgerissen werden es wird wahrscheinlich
noch Jahre in Anspruch nehmen darum sind
auch sehr viele außer atacia weggegangen
ob sie wiederkommen völlig ungewiss
seit sechs Monaten leben die Menschen
mit Staubwolken neben Schuttbergen und
kaputter Infrastruktur die Luftbelastung
ist extrem wegen nicht fachgerechte
Abrissarbeiten schlagen Umweltexperten
und Ärzte schon lange Alarm
beim Abriss wird kein Wasser benutzt das
heißt frei und kommt so und die Luft das
wirkt ein Krebsrisiko genauso wie beim
Feinstaub
es ist die Katastrophe nach der
Katastrophe die auch den Basar der Stadt
trifft das Herzstück von Antakya
weltberühmt für seine tausenden Händler
und für seine Diversität religiös
kulinarisch und architektonisch
metinhüseyinochlu will in wenigen Tagen
wieder öffnen er verlor seine fünf
Bekleidungsgeschäfte und damit seine
Existenzgrundlage
auf geht's haben wir gesagt wir werden
den kaputten Basar von Antakya wieder
aufbauen
werden wir alle zusammen fünf Jahren
besser da stehen als zuvor
Zelt stellte wie diese sehen wir überall
in der Region hathai meist dort
errichtet wo die Beben die Häuser der
Menschen zerstörten
eine Hilfsorganisation hat uns
mitgenommen wer in Zelten lebt hat oft
keine Wahl und muss im Erdbebengebiet
bleiben es ist heiß an diesem Mittag
über 40 Grad
was Sie den ganzen Tag machen frage ich
diese Frauen
wir frühstücken wir essen zum Mittag wir
sitzen herum wir dürfen ja nicht in die
Häuser zurück
das Lager liegt am Rande von Antakya
hier sind 100 türkische und 60 syrische
Familien untergebracht die Männer Bauern
Tagelöhner angewiesen auf staatlich
Unterstützung und Spenden
momentan gibt es hier geradeausgabe es
werden Windeln verteilt und andere Güter
und in ungefähr einem Monat heißt es
können viele umziehen in einen
Containerdorf
türkische Familien hat Ankara
entschieden dürfen zuerst in die
Container die
un-koordiniert die Hilfe und entwickelt
Projekte die Schritt für Schritt die
Lebensbedingungen der Menschen hier
verbessern sollen erklärt mir der
Koordinator
für die Bildung brauchen wir Lehrer für
die Gesundheit Ärzte und
Krankenschwestern wir müssen all diese
Bereiche wiederherstellen das passiert
gerade es hat schon sehr starke
Veränderungen seit dem Erdbeben gegeben
aber schauen Sie sich um all das wird
einige Zeit dauern
das allerwichtigste neben einem
Schlafplatz ist die Versorgung mit Essen
in der mobilen Suppenküche von samanda
gibt es heute Bulgur und frischen Salat
Katrin und ihre Kolleginnen haben selbst
alles verloren können sich hier aber
etwas dazuverdienen zudem ist es eine
willkommene Abwechslung erfahre ich
im Leben und dort keine Küche haben
alles ist umsonst Stadt und Sponsoren
unterstützen uns
[Musik]
zweimal am Tag ist Essensausgabe morgens
und am späten Nachmittag für jeweils bis
zu 1.500 Menschen aus der näheren
Umgebung
diese Art der Suppenküche nur eine von
vielen
wir sind mit Murat verabredet als
jüngster Fernsehkoch wurde er im ganzen
Land populär seit dem Beben engagiert er
sich freiwillig erledigt Behördengänge
geht für ältere Einkaufen viele seiner
Freunde haben die Heimatprovinz hartei
verlassen aber der 24-Jährige will
bleiben
ich bin dafür dass niemand die Stadt
verlässt und alle hier bleiben um wieder
aufzubauen und ich denke besonders wir
jungen Menschen können hier viel
bewirken damit die Stadt wieder auf die
Beine kommt
auch Murat hat seinen Elternhaus und
viele Angehörige verloren er hätte das
Geld woanders neu anzufangen aber er
glaubt fest daran dass seine Zukunft
hier ist
Murat nimmt uns mit an einen Ort den er
mit Aufbruch verbindet zum Kaffee los
Englisch für Verlust es wurde erst vor
einem Monat eröffnet weil Kochen seine
große Leidenschaft ist hilft er hier
gerne mit Bruder alle Gerichte die wir
hier zubereiten sind sehr sehr gut
sein Wunsch ein Hotel mit eigener Küche
nicht in Istanbul nicht den Izmir
sondern in seiner Heimatstadt Antakya
bleiben oder gehen ist zur Leitfrage
geworden ein Viertel der Bevölkerung hat
ein Tag ja schon verlassen
[Musik]
am Ende meiner Reise sechs Monate nach
dem jahrhundert leben besuche ich noch
mal meinen Onkel Michelle
auch an ihn die Frage wo er seine
Zukunft sieht
ich bin hier geboren
alle meine Freunde alle meine Bekannten
sind hier in samanda um meine große
Familie ist zwar außerhalb der Türkei
aber ich bin jetzt alleine und ich kann
hier einfach nicht weg mafi.de
alles was er kennt und liebt sei eben
hier erzählte mir auch sein Garten mit
den selbstgezogenen Pflanzen ob das alte
Haus noch mal wieder aufgebaut wird
steht jetzt noch nicht fest